yo so now that the uh the trade is
actually final felt like I come on here
and
just say to JP how much I appreciated
the four years brother
um you're a champion
uh you grew up you know right in front
of everybody's face in terms of
you know that first year where it was
rough a lot of injuries and
you know
just trying to find a way to go into G
league and coming back and helping us
finish 15-5 down the stretch of that his
second year that's winning a
championship your third year
um and fighting to the end you know this
past year so can't wait to see you
Blossom big fella can't wait to see you
shine in your own situation
just looking forward to you know
competing obviously with being a fan of
of everything that you become good luck
to you and you know CP can't wait to
rock with you brother
it's gonna be different with this on the
same side let's get it let's get it